(audience clapping)
- We can't talk about the Lakers
without mentioning Kobe Bryant.
He was here, I love him.
I fell in love with them even in person.
And that was one of those huge things,
and even if you didn't
know him personally,
it really did hit.
I remember being in my house
and we finding it on the news.
Like, it hit everyone.
And that's how powerful
I do think that sports
and those figures can
be for kids or adults,
and that excitement
and that place in time.
And I don't know, and he
really supported you, I heard.
So that must've been really
hard to come back from,
as a team.
- Yeah.
I mean, we all lost somebody
that was really special
and it's left a void in my life
and a void for all Laker fans.
And I remember when my dad passed in 2013,
Kobe reached out to me
and invited me to have lunch
with him in Orange County.
And he brought his daughter
Gianna along with him.
And he said, "I hope you don't mind,
I brought Gianna with me because
I wanted him to see a woman
in a position of power, and
hear what you had to say.
- Yeah.
And I know what he was doing
was really motivating me
because there's all these
little girls that are looking up
to a person like me in my position.
And that's the kind of
thing that Kobe did,
would motivate, he knew
how to motivate people
and to remind me of how
important what I'm doing is,
and through that we
can honor Kobe's memory
and that's how we keep his legacy alive.
(audience clapping)